[موسيقى]
يعيشون على ارض صغيره مساحتها لا تزيد عن
365 كيلو متر مربع اي ان متوسط المساحه
للفرد هي 150 متر مربع هذه المساحه الضيقه
هي مساحه لاقامه انشطه السكن والانشطه
الثقافيه والاجتماعيه والرياضيه والسياحيه
والتجاريه هذه المساحه غير كافيه
[موسيقى]
دائما انا مش هاكر انا واهلي على طول
مشاكل انا واخوي لانه خص نص باب عقبال باب
بيته غرفه عقبال غرفته بالضبط ودائما
مشاكل من ورا الصغار ومشاكل وضغط يعني
الواحد الله يعينه بروح من الشغل تعبان
ومش حمل مشاكل وبرجع بلاقي مشاكل بالصبح
مشاكل وفي الليل مشاكل برضو هذا كله يعني
ما ليش ذنب فيه يعني نشدناهم كتير وزاره
الاسكان يعني عدد سكان كتير احنا ايش
ذنبنا احنا
[موسيقى]
جزء من هذه الاراضي ما زالت اراضي
الزراعيه وبالتالي ليس هناك اراضي سكنيه
بشكل كبير يمكن انبه حاجه السكان اضافه
الى ذلك نحن نتحدث اساسا عن عجز في
الوحدات السكنيه في قطاع غزه وحاله الفقر
وحاله البطاله التي يعيش فيها سكان قطاع
غزه ادى الى ظهور حاله من العشوائيات في
بعض المناطق المتاخمه للمدن والقرى وبلدات
الفلسطينيه